[Music]  I honestly can't remember why we kept  most of the stuff to begin with we used  to love frying that with mother and  father those days are long behind me  [Music]  by living break  [Music]  MARY POPPINS you came back you seemed  hardly to have aged at all really  one never discusses a woman's age  Michael would have hoped I taught you  better  [Music]  what brings you here after all this time  same thing that brought me the first  time I've come to look after the banks  children ah oh yes you too  what about to lose our home if we things  fall into pieces since your mother  famous mother nothing's gone forever  only out of place it's good thing you  come along when you did Mary Poppins  [Music]  do what  [Music]  so you've been off filling the  children's heads with stuff and nonsense  I forgot what it's like to be a child  [Music]  everything is possible if it be  impossible  [Music]  Oh Riko  [Music]  you